met by it not too cool oh and here's  LeBron whooping cross-court Kawhi  Leonard yes  from downtown vacations leadership the  sports science and math lotta money at  stake  it's his serve free of this first  quarter  [Music]  [Applause]  he gets those big hands on It's A Wrap  especially around that bath the area  here's what a nice feeling it  [Applause]  pretty much mirrors the regular seasonal  all but one morning by our statistical  staff Davis the active I'll put my head  here comes water his Pat stuck it up  back it goes to Kauai and takes  advantage though since the desperation  here forty me honest trying to get into  the win column here this  [ __ ] yes Martha grant chat once you are  Oh Paul George am I wrong give me seven  of eight from doubt